what my life is testimony to is the
reality of the transcendent I am NOT a
flake or an airhead and I do not give
great credence to all the fragile
suppositions of the new age but
nevertheless I tell you here and now the
rationalist is a fool the reductionist
is a [ __ ] because there are things
which haunt this world that are you know
stranger than we can suppose and they
are accessible you just have to know how
to do it and so far as I've been able to
find out there's only one way to do it
and talk is cheap chakras drumming diet
yeah yeah this and then but there are
things which work friends the fact that
there are so many things which don't
work should not cause anybody to lose
heart there is somewhere in that bony
freak show
a reality that before which one can only
respond with awe now we're told that's
not so that the world is cut and dried
that it's all very simple that's the
first myth that you have to dissuade
yourself oh and that's the fastest way
to do that is just take five dried grams
of mushrooms and you will quickly be
conveyed into the atrium of the mystery
and from that vantage point you can see
that my goodness we were sold a line
about the spiritual emptiness
world in the world is teeming with God's
demons and gnomes and a whole pantheon
of who knows what
[Music]